so yeah yeah this is going to be a going
to be a quiz so if you're not on the
Wi-Fi get yourself on the Wi-Fi now the
the username password is on there and
then once you've done that if you want
to go to this URL and make up your own
username and password so yeah obviously
not the same username and password or a
bunch of you will be on the same account
so yeah you won't be able to get to that
URL if you're not on that Wi-Fi network
so make sure you are and if you're
watching this on the livestream tough
like I'm afraid you've just got to play
along using your brain and you know you
can write things down on paper and score
yourself if you want so the reason I'm
asking you for a username and password
is just so you can switch devices
halfway through in case you know one
your phone starts running out battery
and you want to ship your purse which to
your laptop just use the same username
and password and everything will work
the password is stored in plain text on
my machine so don't use like your credit
card number or anything like that unless
you are intending to make a donation and
that will be gratefully received thank
you very much so I'm going to assume
everyone's ready to go I will keep the
URL in the corner of the screen so if
anyone you know loses it you'll be able
to pick it back up I kind of hack this
together on a plane you could probably
break it by trying to break it so please
don't try and break it I've made it so
little Bobby tables can play there's
there's no that's not going to break it
but there are probably other things you
could probably das it so please don't do
that and I want to stress that this quiz
is pretty tough I've seen it get the
better of people who you know do this
kind of study of browser quirks for a
living so if you're the kind of person
who gets really angry and starts
flipping over tables when you don't win
then just maybe stay away from the
tables for a little while ok oh of
course what kind of quiz would be
complete without a price so the
Chromebook pixel is Google's latest
laptop featuring an i5 1.8 gigahertz
dual-core processor 4 gigabytes of ram
and a touchscreen with a higher DPI than
a macbook pro couldn't get hold of one
of those sorry they wouldn't let me but
i did get is a chromecast so i've got
one of those to give away for whoever
gets there the highest score so it's not
quite a pixel but it's very very good so
let's start let's
of really simple and so the URLs there
in the bottom the screen if you need it
again but here's a nice easy start
you've all worked with images in HTML
right okay so here's a div but it has a
source like an image might which
browsers do you think are going to make
a request for that image now on your
phones are on your laptop's you should
be presented with the option so you pick
which ones you think you're going to
make a request and then hit submit if
it's not appearing on the screen or the
icons aren't you can just give the page
a refresh and that should come through
when we're talking about these browsers
I mean the latest versions of each one
so I 10 etc etc you get one point if you
get it right for a particular browser
you lose a point if you get it wrong for
a particular browser so there's a
maximum of four points per question and
a minimum of minus four you can score
negatively you can assume the html5
doctype and there's nothing hidden going
on you know I'm not going to turn around
and say oh but there's a base element
that's changing the URLs there'll be
none of that it's just what's there on
the screen that one line so what we're
seeing here is like a live opinion of
the room as well so the needle swings
one way when you're saying collectively
that yes the browser will make a request
it'll swing the other way if you're
saying no but I'm going to randomize
which way is yes and no for each
question so you can't just look at the
screen and vote along with the room okay
so that's probably enough time I'm going
to close the question in three two one
okay so we can see from this that your
assault saying chrome is going to make a
request here you're less sure about the
other browsers and the answer is no none
of the browser is going to make a
request in this and but it's not
actually is as mad as it seems so this
this doesn't work in html5 but it was
proposed in XHTML too so xcited Tamar
tool allows you to do this put a source
attribute on on anything and it would
replace the content with what you had in
the source and this is really good
because it meant that the the alt
attribute on images became redundant
because you could replace real semantic
content a pretty cool idea but XHTML to
was backwards incompatible and it
carried with it XML stroke onian error
handling and once you invite XML into
your home XML us everything you know XML
is all over the floor up the walls and
in the same way that Smurfs stick the
word Smurf in front of everything to
make it a smurf thing XML does it with
with X you know like you don't want HTML
you want XHTML you don't want frames you
want Birks frames you you don't want
forms you want xforms if you'll XML take
over your life it will turn your
boyfriend or girlfriend into an
ex-boyfriend or girlfriend an exile is
cool with that because you know you
don't need a partner anymore you've got
XML to look after you it seems fitting
that in 2009 XHTML became an expert
ification and it was completely
abandoned and no browsers ever
implemented that source attribute on
elements other than like images and the
things they work on now okay but what
about this so here we've got an image
element it's got sauce it's in the page
but I've spelled image incorrectly I've
put it IM a GE rather than I mg does the
browser treat as an unknown element or
does it make the request the browser
only has to make the request it doesn't
have to display on the page in case you
think that matters xmm was too strict to
work at the web but is HTML this lenient
or other browsers more lenient than the
spec just get your answers in quickly
I'm going to close the question in three
two one and it's closed so we're kind of
edging towards know in all the browsers
all the browsers will make a request for
this image and and they will display it
because in the past a browser decide
that IMG is quite difficult for
developers to remember so they should
support I am a GE as well and we've been
stuck with it ever since which browser
engine do you think we've got to thank
for this yep you've guessed it it is
mosaic back in 1993 the people who
invented the image tag they they put
this alias in and a study in 2005 showed
that not point2 percent of pages were
using this misspelled image tag so any
browser that wants to work on the web
that we have today has to duplicate this
alias the what WG recognized that and
the added it to the spec this is the
parsing spec you know start tag name
image change the token to IMG and
reprocess it don't ask great but this
was actually used in the clever hack
recently alexey 10 came up with this
which i really liked you would use this
in place of your image elements and what
it does is it loads an SVG for browsers
that support SVG and it loads up
ng for browsers that don't so the way a
modern browser would posit is it sees
SVG and it goes okay it's got weight and
height one hundred percent over 100
pixels and it sees this and this is a it
sees this as an SVG image element
because in SVG images are spelled out
full rather than IMG it's got a width
and a height and I'm going to load this
because this is how you define the
source of an image in in SVG because you
know why have links when you can have X
links so and then it sees this and that
doesn't mean anything to SVG images so
it's ignored so we're now showing the
SVG image and all the browser such as
Android to or IE 8 and below they will
pass it like this no idea what that is
i'm going to ignore him or treat it like
an unknown element oh look the developer
has spelled image wrong it's okay i'm
going to correct it for them it's 100 by
100 no idea what that means i'll ignore
that and then oh there's the source of
the image you're going to download the
PNG so it's kind of nice because it
doesn't require javascript and it's a
nice way to conditionally load the you
know the kind of file at the browser
supports we got quite excited about it
and we were tweeting about it the
mistake we made is we did not test it so
a few of us did just that and we found
out something interesting all of these
browsers support SVG but which browsers
will download the PNG as well and I'll
give you a clue it's not all of them not
all of them get it wrong is just one or
some of the browsers are going to are
going to get this wrong and they'll end
up downloading both both the PNG and the
SPG having a close the question in three
two one okay so we're saying no in all
the browsers and yes in IE it's almost
like you've been burned by that browser
in the past well the answer is you are
right Internet Explorer will make a
request for two images hidden it's
because all modern browsers they've got
two parcels built into them it's a
relatively new thing for them to have
but they all have it 1 parser runs ahead
and it goes and it tries and finds
things like it should download like
scripts and images or whatever and then
leave a parser comes along and does the
heavy lifting like building the Dom tree
parsing scripts etc etc and this has a
really large benefit I study we did at
Google we looked at 2000 sites and when
we added this preloader and we've got a
twenty percent speed improvement to get
to
content loaded so it's really useful but
in order to be quick this is pre parser
is a little bit stupid and in internet
explorer it's a bit too stupid at the
moment it kind of gets overexcited it's
like oh look i'm going to show this PNG
i'm going to show this PNG here i go
showing the PNG actually I won't say
it's actually an SVG oh I'll do that
instead so the main parts are seized the
markup and it sees the image but it
misses the SVG context and then the main
part that comes along and goes what why
am I am I downloading PNG it cancels
that download and goes for the SVG
instead but by that point it's made the
connection it's probably got all of the
image by that point the moral here is
don't trust performance tips make sure
you test things at chrome we say tools
not rules which rhymes so I guess it
must be true but always be on the
lookout for existing data or existing
tests that you can run my favorite
stories and science or a tale I don't
know how true it is but involves this
man algis Phi's minh and he wanted to
disprove that life experience was part
of evolution like something that you
happen to you do in life would be passed
down as evolution so the way he was
going to disprove this as he took two
mice and he cut their tails off and bred
them together and then he took the
offspring there and he cooked their
tails off and bred them together the
idea was like we shouldn't end up with
mice being born without tails right and
he was ringing this desperate quite a
while until one of his colleagues
pointed out so of course you do realize
that Jewish people have been
inadvertently carrying out this
experiment a lot longer than you have oh
yeah so he stopped this test and he
would just use that as evidence so what
about this we've got a diff it's
displaying on as an image inside it so
the image won't be displayed but which
browsers are going to download it anyway
so yeah it's not going to render so you
could save to a waste of bytes to do so
or maybe some browsers going to get it
just in preparation thinking it might be
shown when they close the question in
321 okay so a sort of leaning towards
yes but every browser were quite certain
it's going to happen Internet Explorer
the answer collectively you are correct
yes all of the browser's here are going
to download that image and this behavior
is part of the spec so in the browser in
the beginning there is nothing and then
to get sprayed with HTML text will
convert that text into a tree of
elements that we know as the dom when
this HTML when an element is turned into
where Tigers turned into an element the
construction steps for that element to
run and for image it's really
complicated actually creating an image
element but step 14 down here at the
bottom is where it actually makes the
request and request the image so
visibility doesn't matter at all it
doesn't come into it and that's kind of
good because it means that your images
can download before your CSS is
downloaded before your scripts have
downloaded as a downside it meant that
responsive images polyfills did not work
because by the time your javascript gets
to the image it's already started the
download of the thing that was there
already you're just going to add a
second download by changing the source
this won't be a problem in the future
the resource priority spec we've
specified the postpone attribute which
tells an image that it shouldn't display
if it's displaying on among other things
but what if we what if we are using CSS
what then so here we've got a div that's
displaying on and inside there's a div
with a background image so it's kind of
similar to the image one but we saw that
images are ignoring CSS but here we're
actually in CSS land already so are
there any browsers that are going to
going to download that or they just
going to ignore it so once again it's
not going to be displayed so you could
consider it a waste of bytes I'm going
to close the question in three two one
so we're kind of edging towards yes in
every browser I'm afraid not no browsers
are going to download it here not at all
it that's kind of suppose you could see
that as a good thing it's it's saving
bites but what if we did this similar
question it's a div displaying on and it
has a background image so the difference
from the last question is it's all on
one element it's not the images inside
another element as displaying nan does
that change things once again it's not
going to need that background image I'm
going to close the question in three two
one so we're edging towards yes and
every browser a little bit more
confident in Chrome most browsers will
Firefox will not so what's going on here
so once the browser has this tree of
elements it needs to work out you know
what they look like and where they go on
the page and the first step of this is a
style calculation
so it calculates all the styles it goes
through the CSS cascade the style
attributes the font tags if you're from
the 90s and works out what style applies
to each element but not everything gets
it style calculated so this div up at
the top turned out to be displaying on
the browser stops there it doesn't
calculate for their children because
those elements have no impact on the
rendering of the page so it's shortcuts
so if these elements have a background
image the browser just never finds out
about it this div up at the top here is
this plane on but it did have it style
calculated in order to find that out and
that's when the browser will discover
the background image Firefox is a little
bit smarter here in a void so download
but if you change that to instead of
displaying non-use visibility hidden or
a pasty zero firefox with download as
well who's getting it right according to
the specification everyone is the spec
is really vague here it says the browser
may optimize even if the element is just
obscured it's underneath another one but
no browsers are that smart this kind of
freedom in specifications is is kind of
good because it means the browser can do
the right thing given the device the
connectivity maybe even though the
battery percent how much battery you've
got left but it's also scary as it means
you're going to get the browser's doing
different things as I as they try new
stuff with that freedom they have but I
think that kind of diversity is what
makes the it makes the web great it's
not one company driving forward with its
own interests it's lots of companies
driving forward in different directions
and we get this kind of car crash but
with a happy ending and and that's the
web that we have today if you want to
avoid downloading a CSS background
hiding the element isn't enough you need
to put it inside an element that is
displaying on but when you do this
you're just relying on what browsers do
today it's not specified behavior
browsers made change the only surefire
way is make sure the browser doesn't
find out about that background image
don't add the class name that adds that
background or don't add the element to
the Dom at all until you really need it
okay things have been relatively easy so
far we burnt involving javascript so
let's let's get javascript involved what
about this i'm creating an image i'm
giving it a source i'm not putting it in
the document and i'm spelling image
incorrectly like we did before so we saw
in HTML that it was also correcting a ma
GE to IMG but does it do the same in the
Dom do don't do image is even download
when they're not in the document because
once again this is not the browser
doesn't need to render this yet or it
can't render this yet now close the
question in 321 so this is the point in
the quiz where you know the audience
just gets broken and the needles just
drift towards the center of like that I
don't know I don't know what's going on
in this case most browsers will download
Firefox won't and there are two parts of
this explanation as we saw before the
Dom gets parsed and the creation steps
of the element to run this animation
took me a long time which is why you've
seen it three times already but that is
the last time but when the when in
elements just created using Dom stuff
it's still going to run the creation
steps and we saw four images step 14
that is going to be when it downloads
the image we can use this to our
advantage because this one line you can
make a get request to anything that the
machine can access and in fact images
have their own Dom constructor unlike a
lot of other elements so that tiny bit
of code instant get requests to anywhere
else and this is pretty much how Google
Analytics talks back to the server but
we saw before that Firefox didn't make
the request so why what's going on there
when we create this most browsers chrome
safari IE will give us an HTML image
element back whereas firefox will give
us an HTML element it's not an image if
you add it to the page it won't display
an image and the interesting thing is
here it's the only one getting it right
we saw before this is how the the
browser will have the spec deals with
images that are spelled incorrectly but
this is in the parsing spec and we
bypass passing by using create element
we're completely bypassing the parser so
it should well a Firefox gives us an
HTML element it should give us an HTML
unknown element which it does for if you
do create on fubar so Firefox are doing
something special for these images but
it's getting it more right than other
browsers I I think I preferred it when
when we were developing for browsers it
was like there was one bad guy and it
was internet explorer six or seven or
eight and all the other browser seemed
perfect in comparison but I see the
browser scape as being like like an
orchestra where Internet Explorer 8 was
just this kid hitting two cymbals
together and scream
but once we finally kick the screaming
child out of the room and we come back
we start conducting again we realize Oh
everyone's actually a little bit out of
tune we just didn't realize because of
the screaming symbol child of Internet
Explorer so let's just get let's get CSS
involved again but javascript as well
what about this so I'm creating a day of
giving it a background it's not in the
document but everything's spelled right
and valid we saw images download at this
point but what about when when CSS is
involved are we going to see things
download their get the answers in
quickly I'm going to close the question
in three two one so once again the
needle societ into the middle the answer
here is now now no browsers will
download here this is the same as the
display non case the browser won't
calculate the style of elements I
display none they also won't calculate
the styles of elements that aren't in
the document because there's no point
that doesn't affect the rendering of the
page at all okay going to be cruel now
what about this so same again I'm adding
it to the document then I'm removing it
again is it in the document long enough
for the browser to go oh I should
download this this background image or
does it not get to see it long enough
does it does it not bother I'm going to
close the question in three two one ok
so we're suggesting yes because yes it
has entered the document I am afraid you
were all wrong with that one all the
people who said that the the browser
does want to think about styles are
layout until the very last moment and
that's normally rendering when action
needs to change pixels on the screen and
we can't do that or we don't do that
while we're in the middle of JavaScript
so the browsers actually sits back and
waits for that JavaScript block to
execute then afterwards it will go and
look at what's changed and react to that
when it needs to it to render next but
does this change that so same code again
but in between adding and removing it to
the document I'm going to ask for the
text content of the element now the text
content is going to be an empty string
because it is an empty element but it's
just accessing that property going to
change things I'm not even assigning it
to a variable so you know is it just
even going to be optimized away there's
a bit of JavaScript cuz it has no impact
I'm going to close the question in free
to
one almost dead in the middle excellence
the answer is no no no browsers will
make a request getting the text content
is easy it's just going to go through
the Dom finder text nodes can catenate
the values together what about this
similar question but this time innerhtml
rather than text content once again it's
going to be an empty string that comes
back there because the element is empty
but does it behave differently to text
content and the browser's going to do
something different going to close the
question in 321 so we're saying no here
yes you're mostly right Internet
Explorer will make her download here and
the reason for that is because when
internet explorer I don't know I have
absolutely no idea it's some things in
the world cannot be explained and this
is one of them like how it takes three
attempts to plug in a USB cable even
though there are only two possibilities
some things cannot be explained okay so
on the same theme again but this time in
a text once again like the other two
this is going to come back as an empty
string because it's an empty element but
is that going to pave differently is
internet explorer are still going to
make the request erroneously like it did
before is it going to get it correct
this time who knows i'm going to close
the question in three two one so we're
edging towards know a little bit less
shirring Internet Explorer the answer
yes most browsers will make a request
here and this actually kind of makes
sense in an odd way let's make a div
it's got a background image and it's got
some inner HTML is got hello world
inside it but world is inside a div of
its own we add it to the document we ask
for its text content it's hello world
but when we asked but it in a text in IE
Safari and chrome is going to return
this it's got a line break in the middle
and the reason for this is in a text
isn't just a text content it's more like
what you would get if you copy if you
highlighted the element and copied it
and because of this it's got like style
information because the the world is on
a different line because the div is
block level or it is by default and it
is in this case so what actually happens
here is the browser we asked for the
text content it just gets that back but
when you ask for the inner text the
browser has to go
I need to know what the layout of this
element is in order to return this I
need to find out if that this block
level where I'm going to put my line
breaks oh look there's a background
image there and then it downloads it
because it forces it to look at the
Styles most of time the browser will
defer looking at styles as late as it
can but here we forced it to happen
sooner because we've asked for something
that style dependent Firefox didn't make
a request because it doesn't support in
a text it doesn't support the property
at all so that's just undefined that was
that was quite cruel but if we used any
of these properties like out a Teton on
our text but offset left offset parent
Firefox would have made the request as
well sort of ignorant of that those
elements that will require a style
information that's one of the number one
problems with performance that we see on
the web but it's also you can do some
nice hackery with it I mean if you look
at code like this it looks really
expensive but it's not it's really cheap
because the browser is just going to sit
back and watch you just writing this
property to a to an object in its not
going to care about it until that block
ends and once that's all done it will it
will just look at the result and in this
case there's no pixel difference this
can lead to some unexpected results not
just a graphical performance but so
imagine a second practice have a look at
a practical example here is Paul Lewis
in me who we work together we want to go
over there you can tell because we're
pointing let's do it with code we're
going to say left 0% going to set a
transition and then left one hundred
percent we run that code hey off we go
excellent we win at code but if we run
that code again nothing happens and the
reason nothing happens is the browser's
going to batch up the style changes so
we've got we're setting left twice but
the browser is only going to listen to
the last one and we're essentially
saying transition to a hundred percent
but we're already at a hundred percent
so it doesn't move you might have
encountered this and try to fix it with
set timeout and an arbitrary number in
that but what you actually want to do is
at this point just after we set the
first left you wonder the browser to go
and look at that style and actually
think about it and we can actually do
that by putting one of those properties
in offset width or whatever
we do that we can run that code as many
times we want and it will work every
time but you are relying on them
specified behavior when you do that the
web animations API will will save us
there and just before I get kicked off
stage I want to go through the bad side
of that normally using things that
offset width in the middle of your code
can lead to perform as difficulty and
here's an example of that so here I've
got a page with a load of paragraphs and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to set
Chrome's timeline recording which is
going to record everything is going on
resize the screen box and I'm going to
hit that button when I hit that button
all of these paragraphs are going to
become the same size as the green box so
do that press the button and they all
change and that was quite slow and we
can see in the timeline there's a little
spike there and if we have a look at the
the number that comes up there it's like
one point two seven seconds it's it's
very slow but we this little warning
icon on there and if we kind of look
into that we get clue of what's going on
we get this recalculate style layout
recalculate style layup happening over
and over again and that's that's not
looking great the code we're using is
really simple we're just loop through
all of those paragraphs and set the
offset wit for the green block to the
paragraph now the first time we go
through this loop we ask the brows of
what is the size of the green box and it
goes oh I know I know that answer
because I've just drawn it here's your
answer easy peasy and then we set the
the whip to the paragraph but the next
time we come around the loop we ask the
browser wats to wait for the green box
it's like hmm I used to know the answer
to that question but since then you've
been playing around with styles on the
page so I need to go away and have a
think about what you've changed and see
if it affects the the width of the green
blog and that's going to happen on every
loop this is layout flashing this is
interleaving style reads and writes and
it so it's a performance killer what we
actually want to do is just cash that do
the reeds first outside the loop get the
green box width and then go through the
loop and the difference is absolutely
astounding so recording that changing
the whip the green box click the button
it just happens instantly and it's it's
a massive difference that was like 60
milliseconds all in for everything
versus like over a second so if you need
to realize if you need to read something
that style dependent do it before you
start making style changes and am I out
of time my am I done okay but before we
do that and we'll
look at the final scores and see who you
managed to win the chromecast if i can
get a mouse pointer over here right a
moment of tension where's my mouse
pointer let's see if this works okay oh
we've got a draw ah that's the humming
we've got one chromecast we can get
another one that's excellent i do have a
bonus round but we are definitely out of
time who's where are these where are you
two people where you've Oh got one here
and there Oh congratulations guys around
the pots for these guys actually and and
with that I say thank you very much and
i'm going to make way for someone else
thank you very much guys JS